in the last 20 30 years it has now
become a widely shared view among elites
in both parties if you look at both
platforms that parents ought to have
some say over where their children go to
school and that that competition for
children is making schools better what
is at the very top of your education
reform lyst well the my highest priority
is expanding school choice but I'm very
agnostic about what form that choice
must take I think there are lots of
different ways of expanding the number
and quality of choices that parents are
you want tax credits vouchers charter
schools magnet schools right yeah right
I to me which form it takes is largely a
matter of political convenience I think
there are some forms of choice that are
likely to be more educationally
effective more likely to be more
equitably available and so I have my
preferences but I just want to do what
whatever is politically feasible for
expanding the choices and and not only
so that parents have more options but
also so that people working in the
school system have more meaningful
accountability for results that is if
people don't like it they leave what are
you know what are the big benefits of
school choice right well the the big
benefits are that it allows people to
get the type of education they need for
them so we're not all the same we don't
all have the same goals for what our
education should be and choice allows us
to customize that's one big benefit
second big benefit is that choice and
competition help improve average quality
and hold down costs and both of those
are badly needed as well what are the
big obstacles to expanding the palette
of school choice I actually think that
that we're making huge progress I think
if we look at what intellectual opinion
was among elites 20-30 years ago it was
that parents were just bad choosers they
just didn't know what a good education
was and that it was the role of elites
to usher people into the right schools
that did the right things for them so he
when there was choice like magnet
schools 30 years ago these were schools
that were structured entirely to produce
a composition that elites wanted and in
the last 20 30 years it has now become a
widely shared view among elites in both
parties if you look at both platforms
that parents ought to have some say over
where their children go to school and
that that competition for children is
making schools better and so the range
of choices that have expanded with this
we now have you know a huge number of
charter schools when twenty years ago we
had none we have more than two dozen tax
credit and voucher programs around the
country still with a relatively small
number of students and I'm in the
biggest area where I think we've been
held back actually is in the
consolidation of school districts
districts have gotten bigger Roy even in
the last 20 30 years I mean as it seems
everything else in American life and
business and culture is decentralizing
we're still seeing a centralization of
education right in in districts but
we're seeing a decentralization with
charter schools and and with tax credits
and vouchers what are the big obstacles
to broadening school choice well the
biggest obstacle is the teacher union
and their political allies they would be
hurt by expanded choice and competition
because it would put pressure on them to
improve quality and it would shrink
resources available for their own
benefit what's the political calculus to
turn it around where you know parents
and taxpayers are more in charge well
the the calculus is that that every
victory is permanent in every defeat is
temporary so that when choices expanded
it's very hard to take it away from
people because once the habit they like
it and want to invite to keep it the
advantage of the unions have is that
they're well organized and highly
interested in preventing new choice
programs and potential future
beneficiaries of those choice programs
don't know who they are not organized
and can't advocate for them so it takes
an entrepreneur a policy entrepreneur to
introduce a new choice program to make
engage in the fight necessary to expand
it but then once it's made available it
tends to create its own political
support and its own demand for
additional choices right Jay great thank
you very much thank you very much